russian police have arrested hundreds of
people at nationwide protests in support
of jailed opposition leader
alexei navalny observers say more than
400 protesters were arrested today in
more than
50 cities around the country the
protests took place on the same day as
president vladimir putin's annual state
of the nation address
a forceful message delivered on a grand
stage
at his annual state of the nation
address russian president vladimir putin
warned western powers
not to meddle in moscow's affairs
we really don't want to burn any bridges
but if some mistake our
good intentions for indifference or
weakness and intent to burn or even blow
up those bridges themselves
russia's response will be even more
forceful
quick and tough
in recent weeks russia has been building
up its military presence on the
ukrainian border and in crimea
pouring fuel on a simmering territorial
conflict between ukraine
forces and pro-russian separatists this
escalation was met with condemnation
from abroad
but as he delivered his warning to the
west putin was facing head winds at home
across the country people gathered in
protest at news of the deteriorating
health
of imprisoned opposition leader alexey
navalny
a heavy police presence was supposed to
deter those protests
a key aid to navalny was snatched from
the streets in moscow
and locked in a police van on the
grounds of the interior ministry
i think that everything is happening to
scare all the other people
i was detained for just thinking about
showing up at the rally
i will be detained until the late
evening in this police van
but you know perfectly well what you
should do
you shouldn't be afraid but the
crackdown could not prevent protests
even in far-flung parts of the country
like here in the remote siberian city of
ulaan uday
i came here purposefully to raise my
voice against
future and ongoing repressions against
the killing of alexey navalny in jail
against having many political prisoners
[Applause]
the rallies were met with mass arrests
as protesters were dragged into police
vans one by
one politics in putin's russia
increasingly looks
like rule by force
well for more now i'm joined by felix
light from the moscow
times felix it's good to have you on the
program i understand that you were at a
pro-alexei navalny
protest um tell us what did you see
yes well so the the outlook among the
protesters tonight
among the navalny movement was in some
ways a little bit mournful
because after really dominating russian
politics russian opposition politics for
some years now
the navalny movement is facing some
really serious
legal penalties that will essentially
criminalize any involvement with navalny
today's crowd was was big but it wasn't
massive it was
certainly large for moscow standards we
saw certainly perhaps
north of uh of 10 000 people on the
streets of moscow at least today
and it was a crowd of young people of
old people of really sort of cutting
across the coalition of navalny's
support
but there was really was this
recognition that this is perhaps the end
of the line for sort of mass protest
activity in moscow for the time being
we hear that police detained hundreds of
protesters
can you confirm that did you see any of
that happening
i didn't personally see it myself and in
fact though there is there are reliable
reports of several hundred detentions
today
this was already almost rather uh
restrained by the standards of russian
policing certainly in january we saw
really aggressive sort of thorough going
policing and in some cases really savage
violence being meted out to protesters
today we saw less of that and that is
perhaps a deliberate decision by the
kremlin to sort of
take it a little bit easy now and what
about the the health of
alexi navalny the fact that we were
hearing that
he could die at any moment what impact
is that having on
the opposition movement in russia
well certainly it spurred a lot of
people to the streets today you know
many people were saying that they were
there specifically to protest what they
call the killing of navalny and
certainly
we do know that navalny's health is
extremely is well it's hanging by a
thread as one of his doctors has said
um he's of course on a hunger strike
he's also recuperating from uh
poisoning by novichok about about six
months ago so there is a great deal of
reason to be concerned about his health
strangely though in an instagram post
which was ferried out by his lawyers
yesterday
he almost told people not to worry
saying that you know this this potassium
buildup which his lawyers have
have flagged up as potentially causing
cardiac arrest is not to be worried
about and that he
doesn't believe that he's on the brink
of death so we will see
we don't quite know what the state of
his health is and the information we're
getting out of the prison is rather
fragmentary
okay correspondent felix light with the
latest tonight from moscow felix thank
you
now if alexi navalny were to die in
prison would there be consequences for
the kremlin
montford weber is leader of the
center-right european people's
parliament in the european party rather
in the european parliament
he says consequences without a doubt
what we can do is to show to vladimir
putin and to his whole system
how high the price could be if things
went in a
will will go in a wrong direction that
is what we have to show
and that's why for me it's clear if
navalny will
really hopefully not but if this really
will happen that he will die
then i think for example that no stream
two cannot be
uh finished can it be finalized as a
project we have to
tell putin the price is high please
respect international
obligations and and rules yeah clear
words there from mr putin
to talk about that i'm joined now by
manuel zarzin he is a member of
germany's opposition green party he's
the greens spokesman on eastern
europe policy and he's a member of the
german parliament's foreign policy
committee mr tarzin it's good to have
you on the program
to get us started i'd like to read a
quote from the chairman of the foreign
policy
committee norbert rutkin he was quoted
in the new york times as saying
however embarrassing it is for me the
greens have the clearest
stance of all the parties on china and
russia
and he also said the greens are a much
more realistic and preferable partner
for us
on foreign policy nice words for your
party so
if the government asks you what it
should do
next about president putin what will
your answer be
well i think that what mr putin is
calling red lines is actually a red
herring it is clearly that he's trying
to
mobilize his population because he's
under
real criticism and they've got elections
on the autumn
and it's a real tough situation for this
regime for this system of putin
because the people are running away of
the system so they're trying to mobilize
to hold the arm population mobilized by
creating a foreign enemy do you think
he's bluffing though i mean we hear
statements about all of these russian
soldiers amassing along
the border with ukraine is that a
serious threat
or is putin just bluffing
it is for sure a serious threat
he's showing us a variety of options
which they have in hand
from a fast escalation whether even
putting
the ideas of the grounding of it by
helping
so-called own passport holders
in ukraine also he was telling today
that
it would be an asymmetrical uh response
by russia which is nothing else than
an escalation which he's offering
on the other hand it can be just also
that they are trying to technically
swift the power balance in the black sea
region
anyway whatever they're doing is a clear
confrontation in the clear provocation
and i'm sure it will not just go far
they will go on business well i want to
imagine
let's say your party were to win the
election and we have a green
chancellor or we've got a green foreign
minister for germany um what would what
would that person
you for example be saying to ukraine
so it's clear i mean this is the german
foreign policy not only of the green
party of the whole government
that the territory territorial
territorial integrity of ukraine
uh cannot be questioned that germany is
clear at the side of ukraine
and against the russian interventional
war which is taking place in eastern
ukraine
since 2014 but i think it's important
that we have to be clear
on the intentions and the interest of
russia as well russia is not seeking for
peace
in ukraine they're trying to create an
image of themselves that they would be
a negotiating party for creating peace
but
actually they want to destabilize the
country so it is important
to talk about the kremlin as a
destabilizing force
and to try to connect with the russian
civil society and the population in the
country
better than before so it's the year 2021
and russia is a destabilizing force in
the world
i assume then that you think the the
russian policy that has been pursued by
german chancellor angela merkel all
these years
that that policy has been a complete
failure
now well let's say that way um it has
been at some points
it was a clear stance and other points
especially with the pipeline nordstrom 2
the german policy towards russia was
actually
not putting ground edge on this position
but
showing that if it's about economical
interest perhaps germany might have a
different opinion and is even splitting
up europe's interest so
it has to be germany now seeking for
more uh
union in the european union position
towards russia and also for
being more clear in stating what we see
about the russian policy
internally against the civil society and
opposition
and externally for example regarding
ukraine does not
mean that the whole policy from the
government was a complete failure
but at least it was not clear enough and
what about
nord stream too should that project
be killed
i personally think it should be killed
but what the german government could at
least do is
saying that they are not politically
supporting it anymore
if the chancellor was saying that she
doesn't support the project
this would be an important political
stance which would have also economical
impact
on the stock
markets uh rating of augustan companies
let me just ask you before we run out of
time
um the protests in russia over the
imprisonment of alexei navalny what did
they
say about vladimir putin and how should
germany react to what's essentially a
domestic
russian issue
this is a domestic russian issue for
sure and we will not influence it
we cannot influence it but as we are
interested in the country of course we
are really closely following and
interested in what's happening
in russia but one sentence more if
somebody is poisoned with a
internationally
illegal substance of chemical warfare
like novichok
this is not an internal issue of any
country anymore
it doesn't matter where it happens if
something like novichok is used it is
in the same moment up to international
law and international case
and no country can claim it's an
internal issue
okay manuel tarantine a
foreign affairs specialist with
germany's green party mr tarzan it's
good talking with you we appreciate
the time and the insights please come
back and talk with us again
thank you have a good night
you